[Applause]
these scenes have never been seen in Tel
Aviv
riot police break up a protest agreed in
advance with authorities using crowd
control tactics familiar to Palestinians
in occupied territory
certainly not familiar to Israelis in
Tel Aviv
the protesters referenced the Israeli
settler attack on hawara
last week Israeli settlers carried out
at least 300 attacks including shootings
arson and a rampage through Palestinian
villages in the Annapolis Area of the
occupied West Bank including olora
whilst these protests were more broadly
about reforms to Israel's legal systems
and not about the events in Hawaii
Israeli Police use tactics never been
seen before prompting the Prime Minister
himself to address the nation
it's not allowed to beat up policemen
it's not allowed to disrupt the
country's life or to block main roads I
understand that here there's someone
who's looking to create Anarchy called
yellow Pete
protesters angered by violence gathered
and Nan Yahoo's home
the demolished their democracy but
Netanyahu isn't no mood to give in he's
still pushing the changes to the Supreme
Court that Sparky's protests eight weeks
ago determined they pass despite the
hundreds of thousands of people who have
come out on the streets in opposition to
it Imran Khan Al Jazeera occupied Easter